[Musique]
bonjour eh bien nous voilà donc une
panne plus dans notre cuisine avec l'ami
pierrot pour bien pour mettre à
l'honneur un produit et une recettes du
terroir
alors aujourd'hui la recette c'est vous
l'avez vu le ragoût de mouton mais
attention le ragoût de mouton à la mode
du nord un pur way le ragoût de mouton
avec des haricots avec apple pomme de
terre avec un petit peu de ma vie voilà
comme ça se faisait sur votre nom c'est
parfois le rappeler nous dans le nord a
franchement du plus dur un terrain c'est
vrai bon et quant aux produits bien de
produits c'est le mouton boulonnais qui
est un vrai produit du terroir il est
l'origine de la race bien entendu c'est
la région de boulogne sur mer dans le
pas de calais où il y avait au début du
siècle qui avait plus de 400 mille têtes
de boutons de cette race là et puis
après la race à peu a pratiquement
disparu
en 84 ont considéré qu'il n'y avait plus
de boutons de la race boulonnaise et
puis il ya quand même quelques amoureux
du du tiroir de la tradition qui ont dit
quand même on va lancer un appel par
voie de presse pour savoir si qu'ils ne
resteraient pas encore quelques
spécimens çà et là
eh bien surprise il ya eu dizaines
d'éleveurs qui ont dit oui nous on a
encore des moutons boulonnais et depuis
eh bien on a retrouvé 8 milliards 800 à
900 1 800 1 900 tête de prêts et de
dépôts de sélection ont permis de
remettre à l'honneur cette race qu'on
aperçoit là vous voyez c'est une race
qui est des caractéristiques très
particulières elle a une tête très fine
avec
1 et pointu et un boudoir sur le sur le
nez et c'est un mouton qui est très très
prolifique avec
des maires qui sont paraît-il très très
attentive et avec des agnelles qui sont
aussi précoce sexuellement c'est ce que
j'ai vu c'est à dire que elles donnent
leurs animaux très tôt dans l'année et
en particulier ce qui est un point
important ce sont les animaux qui sont
arrivés à maturité pour pâques pour le
fameuse agneau pascal voilà si vous
voulez plus de renseignements sur le
bouton boulonnais que vous avez
découvert et bien vous pouvez écrire à
l'association des éleveurs de moutons
boulonnais dont l'adresse s'inscrit sur
l'écran
bon maintenant environ 1 c'est l'heure
de la recette dans du ragoût de mouton
on a dit façon du nord
voilà notre les ingrédients or les
ingrédients évidemment il faut des
moutons comme morceau
aujourd'hui on a choisi des codes
découverte est un petit peu de coller ou
colliers les deux se disent on va
essayer certains vous pouvez faire des
pas faire ça avec du reste de boutons 6
avec lui un gigot bayonne qui restent
des monceaux djigo un peu de même avec
du morceau ferions tout recommencer à
faire soit vous alors évidemment il nous
faudra le faire eux recolorer dans le
stade où on a choisi le stade ou pour
faire vraiment d'une heure au lieu de
mettre du beurre dans le dos 50 g de
sade ou comme ce sera coloré nommé trois
un petit peu d'oignons hachés à peu près
200 g
ensuite tout sera bien coloré oignons et
moutons nous ajouterons de trois pierres
de paris iii iv coeur de paris sa
défense sur le jeu le l'épaisseur des
ricoh donc ça on en juge mais à peu près
3 kg de farine et ensuite on nous avons
des glaces et à l'eau tout simplement
quand ils seront cuits nous ajouterons à
1 500 grammes
nous ajouterons donc 500 grammes de coke
sont déjà en train de fuir puisque j'ai
déjà bien accueillir parce que les
haricots c'est long pour les cuire à
plat comme la main tendue lauriers alors
là méritent qu'on va les mettre à cuire
avant de les mettre dans leur avoue on
va les cuire à peu près trois quarts
d'heure à une heure c'est pour ça que ça
commence déjà à cuire j'ai aimé depuis
stocks diminuent et dont vous mettez 5 à
600 grammes bariteau salut pour
l'appétit que vous avez évidemment et on
va rajouter 300 g de pommes de terre 3
400 grammes et 200 g de n'avait coupé en
tout petits morceaux avant mais après
après donc voilà en tout cas de gens et
puis celle des coûts de gérance du thym
du laurier comme d'habitude on va
pouvoir commencer
donc faire colorer notre mouton alors
voyez mes morceaux là ici c'est cesser
les bombes en soi et bars ou des
morceaux de 120 à 150 g
parce que chez moi j'ai l'impression que
quand on faisait draghi mais ça va
paraître en mai
si vos morceaux j'étais souvent les
restes de moutons qui servait de toit
voilà alors bien les faire saisir
confusion une belle couleur
vous avez dit combien il avait là alors
nous avons bis comme c'est faux si
personne il ya douze morceaux de bois
tout 120 à 150 g
donc si son numérique tôt en cuir sur le
côté tranquillement alors le ragoût de
mouton ça fait quand même partie des
plats mijotés sadi les posters
tranquillement l'idéal c'est de le faire
l'après midi et puis leur faire
réchauffer pour le lambda musique comme
ça vous fait tranquillement en mes
collants l'après-midi mesdames et
messieurs mais c'est bon et chauffe
l'état à ses meilleurs souvenirs durée
copé a comme on dit à lille
ouais alors comme déchets petit pierre
vous aussi il y avait du rattaché vous
revient de sa mère de l'essonne un
faitout en fonte noir 1 sur la
cuisinière à charbon là je vois encore
ça me fait tout et on prenait vraiment
souvent les restes de viande de la base
de viande à dire en début semaine si on
avait fait un gigot le dimanche paris
voilà jamais récupéré l'os du judo tous
les morceaux qui est l acier dans le
plat et sa mijoté avec les risques aux
pommes de terre alors l'une
naturellement bien rico à peu près 600 g
on va mettre les petits navets les
couper en petits ont subi on n'est pas
que jamais de la 17e pas de laver n'est
pas d'eux n'avait évidemment
voilà c'est en train de pleurer quand ça
commence à colorer nous avons rajouté me
200 g d'oignons hachés y ait des oignons
ça vient du goût
à peu près à ben ouais en fait c'est du
mouton aux agneaux vous avez c'est le
bon mais entre lannion et le mouton
saleh à des proxy c'est quand même un
petit bouton on est quand même en hiver
ouais alors mais boucher vous avez vu
nous ont donné des beaux morceaux
1 parce qu'ils nous fichent own way donc
mon boucher luc m'a donné un bon morceau
est vraiment mais naturellement comme
vous dites avec les restes de viande
condat chez qu'on a normalement quand on
fait un gigot qu'on fait des mêmes à
carré d'agneau des fois surtout pas
faire brûler les oignons non plus parce
que si les oignons brûle vous avez le
après en fin de cuisson vous avez
saisonniers ou noir qui remonte dans ce
ragoût c'est quand même pas ragoûtant
voyez tout le saignant de mon demande un
lieu où commença à partir dès que ça
commence
voyez tout le saignant d'affront le voit
bien
j'ai donc rajouter mais trois cas de
farine en 3 cuillères de farid ça fait à
peu près 70 g 80 g de farine
c'est pourquoi ça la salle est pour lier
voilà trente ans quand même épaisse et
je vais faire comme à paris à soupçon
une à deux minutes et ça pour l'instant
oui je vais rajouter deux à trois
gousses d'ail 1 génisses et entière on
peut les acheter
j'ai mis les lycées entière suite
tombera dessus a comme une fête du prg
avec mais c'est meilleur parce que sinon
h et sakho et je vais mouiller à l'eau
jusqu'à hauteur alors dans la grande
cuisine peuvent être du fond blanc j'ai
mouillé auteurs voyez pas jusqu'à
hauteur pour recouvrir en l3 ailleurs m
donc on va médecins on va ajouter notre
teint notre lauriers mais plus le giro 2
à 3 on a organisé et on va l'installer
alors salle celle pareil toujours voyez
je sais ce qu'il faut c'est à vous quand
même après à goûter entre deux senneurs
match versements sont vous donc voilà
nous allons le mettre à cuire sera vous
ici donc il va bouillir il va cuire un
peu près pendant 50 minutes dans 50
minutes mais ricco nous nous retrouvons
dans 50 minutes mais ricco seront
presque puis mais leur mantra 20 à 25
minutes savait par le haricot un targui
remontant il ya ce petit qu'il faut
trouver dont on mettrait paris tôt nos
pommes de terre non avez vous verrez ça
va tout seul donc on va attendre une
cinquante minutes quand même voilà
voilà cinquante minutes à peu près que
ce bouton est en train de cuivre disons
que ça mousse à samus parce que yann
c'est le grain du mouton qui mourra peu
à ce qu'on appelle mieux être grand et
du savon c'est un peu ça c'est une
simplification au modèle bachelot qui
faisait la technologie dans le sport la
cuisine ah ouais bonne mémoire
alors on va simplement alors oui qu
est-ce qui s'achemine vers des pierres
et un peu frais des soins à dur le
regardais pas dur où il ya des afin de
vous évidemment mais regardez il manque
quand même un ils sont durs donc on va
aller on va les rattraper
il reste 20 minutes de cuisson à peu
près celle à ce petit truc qu'il faut
trouver le petit ménage et on peut
remettre le talent laurie avec au bout
un holà la sienne et rico du nord et la
gauche ouais ouais
alors on peut le faire au site à leurs
geôliers de le dire on peut très bien le
faire on stage au lieu il y en a qui
font des petits plats jolivet ou alors
je mets mes haricots
donc il ya peu près 20 minutes cuisson
je vais rajouter des pommes de terre 4
500 g de la découper en petits morceaux
valeur en petits morceaux au sommet pas
de menu les bonnes manières et ferait
tourner du deuil en est fier et alors
les petits n'avaient alors là encore
venue du morceau tout à l'heure et
ajustera sa valise petit bourg à tort
que le petit goût mais pour le mettre un
petit porto pour pas retrouvé le morceau
a ralenti en mai et on n'est pas obligé
le met donc ça va durer un ça va
ça va savoir fond il faut que l'on
reconnaisse pas et ça sentira pas dans
mon bateau
mais ça va donner cette particularité
alors je vais vérifier à prague ou de
pyro allez encore un petit peu de sel en
vérifiant précisément à ce moment là et
ici ça va me sauter pendant 25 à 30
minutes et nos travaux va être fait à
eybens finalement peu près une heure
prendre pack 1h40 que notre tir à vous
de vous tout est en train de tuer et là
en principe c est âgé voyais à déguster
et bien alors pierre ça s'est ratatiné
un petit peu évidemment le bouillon le
toutou est réduit les pommes de terre et
y est pré cuits et c'est comme chercher
droit cha doit démêler pour ses bons
avec guti soir alors comment
prépare-t-on mais non mason directement
ou indirectement dans l'assiette à bord
enfin c'est vraiment un club vraiment un
flop qu'on aime bien de dans le nord
vont mettre qu'un morceau on va pas
faire les gros moments ici un hélico ou
les pommes de terre bien pendant et les
navets on les voit plus à les laver
c'est parce que j'ai dit qu'il y avait
des navets sinon sentirait pas qu'ils
allaient la vespière on sent presque pop
assez présent mais on les voit pas du
tout on s'entraide fondant alors là
vraiment tout et fondant sa se démêlent
fr et s'appelait cola c'est pas mal
célèbre nouvelle cuisine avec des ricoh
bien faire pour bing dans l'assiette non
là c'est vers 17 éval chine raptor
bollée et ben écoutez moi vers 6 0
[Musique]